It's my pleasure to welcome to the program
today.
Jonathan Franklin, an investigative journalist
who writes for The Guardian, is also author
of the 2015 book Four Hundred and Thirty Eight
Days An Extraordinary True Story of Survival
at Sea, which I recently read and recommended
to the audience. Jonathan, it's really great
to have you on.
Yeah, thank you so much. And I'm glad you
like the fisherman boat story. This is a guy
who was on a boat all by himself for 14 months
and somehow survived. So, you know, for all
of us who've been through lock down and confinement,
there's a lot of interesting issues to help
us get through.
Yeah, but, well, maybe we'll start there.
So for people who aren't familiar with the
story of Joseph Salvador Alvarenga, he is
originally a Salvadoran fisherman who, while
working as a fisherman in Mexico in a storm,
ends up drifting off to sea in a 25 foot boat
originally with his would it be called like
first mate or just sort of like an assistant?
I guess we would say, right? Yes. And ultimately,
because of the storm, did not make it back
and actually survived, as the title of the
book suggests. Four hundred and thirty eight
days now at the time was the previous longest
known sort of precarious survival. The seven
day incident.
No, I think there was another one like two
hundred or something, but this of four hundred
and thirty eight days and we're talking on
a tiny boat. I mean, not much longer than
an SUV.
Yeah. And so it's an incredible story. And
obviously it exceeds the scope of our conversation
to tell it all. But needless to say, it's
an incredible story that is filled with both,
you know, everything from innovation in terms
of how he survived to complete and total heartbreak
and the reality of what happens after being
essentially alone for the large part of that.
Four hundred and thirty eight days. When you
take a story like that and you want to tell
the story and it's someone else's story to
tell, how much are you interviewing? What's
your approach? What do your notes look like?
And how do you end up turning it into the
coherent narrative that it became?
Well, it's really interesting you ask that,
David, because this was a victim of, you know,
intense trauma. He goes off fishing for the
weekend, as you say. He loses his motor. He
loses his buddy, who actually dies along the
trip. He's almost starved to death. He's in
huge seas. He has to catch fish with his hand.
He has to eat raw birds. And somehow he kept
it together. And so when I first heard about
this, I didn't believe it. I was like, oh,
because he didn't they didn't look they didn't
look so skinny when he came off the boat.
Some things didn't add up. But on the other
hand, I figured if he had faked it, that was
probably a pretty amazing story also. So either
way, I had a story and I flew to El Salvador
and I tried to interview him and he couldn't
talk. It was he was so in shock. I was it
was one word answers almost like yes or no.
I spent hours just trying to loosen him up.
And he was in shock. He would sweat. He had
nightmares. So it was over the course of five
or six months where I ended up asking him
about twenty five hundred questions, which
turned into five hundred pages of conversations.
And those five hundred pages of conversations,
which was an exclusive deal that I made with
him, is the basis for the book.
In the book you describe many conversations
and I'm interested in narrative nonfiction.
There's a lot of different approaches to dialog
and sometimes like just to pick somebody,
Ben Mezrich will sometimes say that that he's
using sort of creatively recreated dialog
that he feels tells the gist of what took
place, but is not necessarily literally accurate
or that stories may be combined or separated
or whatever the case may be. What was your
approach and sort of describing and telling
the conversations that took place on the boat
between Kosei and his his crewmate?
Well, the interesting thing here is that the
protagonist, Jose Salvador Alvarenga, about
thirty three years old, had never gone to
school after about second or third grade.
So he couldn't read, he couldn't write, but
he fully functioned in society. And one of
the things I learned is that when you're illiterate,
you also have the ability to develop an amazing
memory because you got to keep a lot of things
in your head if you can't read or write them
down. That's interesting. I had a fantastic
memory and I can see it when I would interview
him about a certain scene when he caught his
first bird and two months later I would interview
him again and he just nailed it. So he really
had a fantastic memory. And he you know, the
dialog is in the book is not that extensive.
I only use dialog that I would pretty sure
I could get from his side of the dialog and
then he would tell me the other side of the
dialog. But the fascinating thing is he's
often doing a monologue because he's out in
the middle of the ocean. So the monologue,
you know, he can tell me what his monologue
was. So we have these amazing scenes where
he's talking to a whale shark for days and
days where he talks to a whale shark. He trains
a bird to be his pet and his pet becomes I
mean, the bird becomes his pet and his companion.
Even when his buddy dies, he props up his
buddy and he talks to the corpse for a week
because he figures talking to a corpse is
a lot better than being totally alone. Right.
You mentioned that it wasn't just you who
was skeptical to some degree of the story
initially. And when you consider that the
one, you haven't mentioned this detail, but
he actually washed ashore with that same twenty
five foot boat in the Marshall Islands, in
the Pacific, in the middle of nowhere. And
one of the elements that seems most compelling
in the story is that, of course, there's no
doubt that it's the same boat he left Mexico
with. How important is that detail in convincing
you and others of the story?
Well, that detail, like how did the boat get
there, I mean, you know, you get fed ex a
boat, right? And the interesting thing is
when the guy lands the he has no interest
in talking to the press, he refuses to talk
to the press. He calls the press cockroaches.
And he's trying to forget this trauma. If
you're going to scam it, it's probably because
you figure the publicity is going to get you
something. So if you're going to scam it,
it's unlikely your first move is to tell the
press to blow up. There's that. But on a science
level, I don't know anything about ocean currents,
especially when I started this. So I went
to the Scripps Institution of Oceanography
in University of Hawaii and the US Coast Guard
and all three volunteered very generously
to use tracking software for ocean currents,
drifting boats. And the University of Hawaii
had just put a bunch of GPS drifters in off
the coast of Mexico months earlier. And it
lines up perfectly in terms of if you're going
to throw something like a boat off the shore
of Mexico, it's going to end up in the Marshall
Islands.
So that part also checks out from all three
of those, the Coast Guard, Scripps and University
of Hawaii.
So this this is a fascinating story. I recommend
it again to the audience. The book is four
hundred and thirty eight days now to talk
about some of the other things you've done.
I want to talk about the Venezuelan assassin
sort of rehab camp in a moment. But before
we do that, in the 90s, I believe it was when
you were reporting for Playboy magazine, you
interviewed Timothy McVeigh. Is that. That's
right.
That is right. I'm one of the few people in
our face to face to face with Tim McVeigh
in El Reno prison.
So Timothy McVeigh, of course, the perpetrator
of the 1993 World Trade Center bombing. What
are the circumstances of that interview?
Well, the circumstances are is that I I was
always curious about Mikveh because, you know,
horrendous act. I mean, what causes you to
put a bomb in a civilian building? And when
I look back on it, I find that McVeigh had
been in the big red one infantryman, very,
very well decorated US Army soldier. And when
I started to look at what he did in the first
Gulf War in nineteen ninety one, he was involved
in a pretty horrendous massacre where a bunch
of M1 tanks had bulldozers put on the front
of them. And instead of going trench mano
a mano and the trench warfare, they just buried
the Iraqis alive. About two thousand were
buried alive. And reporters at Newsweek won
a Pulitzer Prize for the cover up of this
story.
You know, big deal, two thousand people buried
alive. That breaks a few contexts of codes
of war. Yeah, McVeigh's job was to shoot off
the survivors with machine guns. So you can
kind of see that without justifying blowing
up Oklahoma, which I'm not doing. And I don't
want to take it that way. You have to understand
that the first time this guy was involved
in a huge, horrendous massacre, he got medals
for it. He was applauded. You know, he he
had killed before. It's very interesting and
very important, I think, to look at the first
time he killed. So when I went to the prison,
that's where I talked to him about was his
war experience because I had interviewed everybody
in his tank before I interviewed McVeigh.
So when I go to interview him, my first question
is, Jim, what was the name of your pet kangaroo
rat when you were in the Gulf War?
And he's like, how do you know? I had a pet
kangaroo rat? And I was like, Hosie told me
how, you know, to say I was I was the driver
when I was out snowboarding with Hosie. You
were hanging out with Ozzy? Yeah. And so all
of a sudden all those barriers broke down.
And he's just giving me the inside story of
what he did in Iraq and how for him, Oklahoma
City was an echo of violence perpetuated by
the US government against all these people
were buried alive in a trench. So there was
for me, I thought it was very important to
figure out where does somebody go that kind
of hyper violent.
Yeah, what one of the commonalities that I've
heard from folks who have interviewed those
who are known for or have committed just disgustingly
extreme acts of violence, is that when they
sit down with them in a room, there's two
things that are common. One, how sort of unremarkable
they are sometimes physically some. I mean,
I think I think with it totally true in this
case. Yeah. I mean, I think like with Charles
Manson, that's a big thing where he's just,
you know, this just kind of this small, unremarkable
guy. But also and this is a weird term to
use, how normal sometimes these folks can
seem. And there's a lot of kind of connotations
to that term. But but what was your sort of,
like, general impression of the man?
Actually, I totally agree with you, because
people, you know, people want to see a monster.
And probably I wanted to see a monster and
I couldn't help think like this is the guy
who like the neighbor who shovels your driveway
in the snow. You know, he's a guy. He's from
Buffalo, New York. So he knows about shoveling
snow. Right. And or it's a guy a guy you could
talk at a bar.
He was he was clearly intelligent, sophisticated
vocabulary. Pretty damn good writer. You know,
you can call misguided and saying whatever.
But the guy had done a fair amount of reading
and, you know, he had he had his own political
philosophy. Whether you believe it or follow
it isn't the point, really. But this was not
some jackass. This was a guy who, for his
own his own twisted reasons are in his mind,
his own logical reasons felt he had to attack
the US government.
And so I really like I said, I was very interested
in finding out about his first kill when when
when I've talked to former KKK types, white
nationalists, etc.. One of the things that's
frequently mentioned is that the way they
got pulled into the air, their extreme ideology
in the first place came typically from a sort
of opportunistic situation. Typically, they
describe lacking a feeling of purpose or empathy
given towards them as children or as teenagers
at some point in their lives. And the people
that brought this extreme ideology to them
brought the ideology really could have been
anything but it was the fact that someone
was paying attention to them. There was something
approximating, hey, somebody seems to care
about me.
No, I call it tribal. A tribe has adopted
me. I saw this. I went to Las Vegas and spent
a bunch of time with the young teenage nazis'
of Las Vegas. And why were they Nazis?
Not because they were anti-Semitic or because
they knew much about Hitler. It's because
their parents were working. Twenty four, seven
and their 17 year olds and the people who
scooped them up were a bunch of nutcase white
supremacists. Right.
The ideology could have been anything that
they were sucked into.
It could have been. Greenpeace, I mean, they
you know, they needed they needed a tribe,
they could have easily been protesting against
tar sands and doing something, in my view,
is positive for the world. That could have
they could have been building houses for the
poor. They needed to be part of a tribe. They
found a pretty terrible tribe. But you can't
deny that most 70 year old need a tribe and
their parents are not usually included.
So how does that compare thinking now of when
you spent this time with the four former hitmen
in Venezuela? How how does it compare with
how they were originally pulled into being
hitmen?
Exactly. I think I think these guys could
have been hit by the German soccer stars.
You know, what happened is I have some friends
in Venezuela and they told me they were running
a rehab camp for hitmen. And I was like, what?
And so I flew up there and drove out there
and went out to the backwaters of Venezuela.
And sure enough, there was a hit man rehab
camp and they said I could go camping with
the newest group who were seven or nine different
heads of different gangs. And they were guys
who hated each other, who would have likely
killed each other, would center assassins
to kill each other to each other's troops.
So they were stripped of their weapons and
they were just given like flour and corn and
matches and and they were stuck on the top
of a hill surrounded by armed guards. And
they had to just hang out for two or three
days cooking, eating and talking around the
campfire.
And so who who organizes that? I mean, in
other words, how how does one get into a position
to be one of the hitmen? That's part of that.
Is it is it under duress that they're doing
this or whether they get the they get out,
they get recruited by a local businessman
who had been a victim of armed robbery. And
when he started to poke into the armed robbery
suspects, he realized they were hitmen and
he offered them instead of turning them into
the cops, he offered to let them work on his
on his rumph. In his rum factory is a big
rum factory. So he tried to get rehab them
on his own. And then they started they showed
up with the whole the whole gang. It's like
you're taking a stray dog and then the whole
pack comes in. He took in two of these guys
and the next Monday they were all piling saying
we want to be rehab. So he hired a psychologist.
He hired some former cops, and then they go
head hunting. They single out the most dangerous
gang leaders in the hills outside of Caracas.
And they and they convinced them, which is
not an easy process, to come try and go straight.
And I was there living with them for about
two or three days on this mountaintop with
all these killers. And I said a little video
camera and I was just videotaping them, getting
them to confess their sins.
And so what what stands out to you about those
conversations and those interactions?
Pretty remarkable that have a group of twenty
one year olds who give zero value to human
life, I don't know who to blame, but they
just they would kill a taxi driver because
they didn't want to pay five bucks. They saw
one guy killed the classmate because he made
fun of him in seventh grade about his homework.
And these guys were hardcore and they assumed
they were going to die. If you if you lived
to be twenty nine, they called your grandfather,
you become a grant. You know, that was like
like a noble title. No, nobody was expected
to make it to 30. So when you have that kind
of hopelessness, apparently it's still kind
of shocking. Killing somebody for money or
for fun or for because you're in a bad mood
is extremely common in a place like Venezuela
where if you give me a thousand dollars, I
can get a rocket launcher. I mean, it's just
a huge black market of guns in Venezuela.
So you had a lot of desperate, hopeless, violent
men with access to heavy duty weaponry, just
a recipe for problems.
You know, one of the things that some will
assert is that to some degree, given the right
economic circumstances and political circumstances
that anybody placed into the situation you
just described could end up as one of these
twenty one year old hitmen, how do you react
to such a claim? I mean, could it could it
really be anybody?
No, I totally don't buy it. I don't believe
I don't believe that. Know, if you look at
that famous study where people were supposedly
torturing with electroshocks and that the
study doesn't hold up. And if you look at
that, that didn't happen. Most people refused
to torture. You know, Lord of the Flies is
fiction, you know. So I definitely strongly
disagree that most of us have a potential
hitman inside us.
What was the one? I'm speculating, but is
there some risk to leaving that lifestyle
in Venezuela? And the people where were the
people that were at this camp? Were they taking
a risk by saying, I'm going to quit this?
Yes and no. They were taking a risk, but staying
in as hitmen is even more risky.
I mean, you've got to you know, being a hit
man is like, you know, your career is like
like it's like the NFL. It's like three point
seven years and then it's over.
And it's part of that because there's a risk
of getting caught and prosecuted or is most
of the risk not from the legal system?
You know, these were a group of 30 men and
they were down to like six of their six of
them were still alive almost all year. So
the average age of these guys getting killed
in combat street urban combat was about 18
or 19 and they were all Muslim. They were
showing me their bullet holes.
They all knew how to treat bullet wounds,
which is pretty remarkable. You know, for
17 year olds who know how to treat bullet
wounds, they used to piss on their bullets
before they go to combat because they were
sure I don't think it's true, but that that
if there was urine on the bullet, that it
would cause a deeper infection on the cops.
Wow. These guys these guys were out there.
And in fact, a few days after my interview
with the leader of the group was caught by
another group and and chopped into pieces,
they did more than murdered himself. So this
was a hyper violent, crazy world. And I was
trying to just live with them and trying to
get them to go on camera and tell me how it
ended up this. And there are no easy answers.
And I wish I could say keep your kids away
from fortnight and they won't be hitmen, but
I don't think it's that simple.
No, no, it seems it seems not to be. What
are you what are you working on right now?
Right now, I'm doing a book on a true story
of a cruise ship that gets hit by covid. That's
a look at how the passengers and the crew
come together. This is kind of the last cruise
ship to go out before the world looks down
and the people start to die. They get sick.
And so it's a story. It's kind of a.
It's a thriller, but it's also a beautiful
story of how a community at sea, two thousand
people had to find a way to survive because
they were just they were adrift for weeks.
No country would take them.
How many how many interviews do you do for
a book like that?
Hundred and fifty hundred and eighty. Wow,
wow.
And is it even possible to keep the sort of
intertwined nature of the one hundred and
fifty stories straight in your head, or do
you really need to rely on on notes and documentation?
You know what I can do with my head? I got
I got seven dollars most of my brains otherwise
occupied.
Hey, I'm curious, you know, the narrative
fiction, a narrative nonfiction genre is very
interesting to me. And I've read, you know,
diverse narrative nonfiction, including your
work. And I mentioned in my email to you Ted
Conover, who I interviewed, who's done interesting
work, Jon Krakauer, known for into thin air
and into the well. What are some of when you
think of the genre, what books and authors
do you think of?
I think a copy on the French prisoner, which
may or may not be a narrative nonfiction,
because the publisher on his deathbed admitted
there was a lot of it went well beyond Ben
Ben Rich's idea of creating dialog. That sounds
good. Yes, but but on fantastic, fantastic
book, Into Thin Air, still a classic, perfect,
perfect storm.
The book, Perfect Storm is brilliant. I mean,
the movie the movie is well done, but the
book is brilliant. And I guess those and I
have to I have to say, what's interesting
about the one I did for four hundred and thirty
eight days is they did an audio version of
it. And I've never really paid much attention
to audio books, but this one has gone crazy.
And I think for any of your listeners who
like audio books or need an inspiring story,
it's about seven or eight hours. But the reader,
George, I don't know. But he did a great job
to have a great, really good reader and a
thrilling tale. So people know people who
are depressed or even suicidal or just going
stir crazy like most of us. The audio version
of four hundred and thirty eight days, half
the time you can get it free on Amazon and
get it free if you can. But it's a it's a
really it's a not because the books a tool.
Obviously I make money on books, but the whole
point of this book was to hopefully stop people
from suicide like that. The goal of the book
was if one person reads this book and doesn't
commit suicide, that that was the goal of
the fishermen. And I set up in the beginning
because the fishermen said, look, I've been
through a mental strength, physical strength.
If I don't kill myself, if I can make it,
you can. So I think there's a really there's
a really strong, you know, resilience and
survival here that goes, you know, it touches
a lot of people. And unfortunately, a lot
of people need that message right now.
But well, well, well said. We've been speaking
with Jonathan Franklin, investigative journalist,
writes for The Guardian, author of Four Hundred
and Thirty Eight Days.
Jonathan, I so appreciate your time today.
Thanks. Well, thank you very much. And I appreciate
your questions of your interview. Thanks.
Well, thank you very much. And I appreciate
your questions of your interview.